I love nursing.
And I also love innovation.
However, often when I speak
about innovation
within the field of nursing,
I’m met with:
"Ugh."
And it's understandable.
Innovation in technology
within the health care sector
is growing really fast.
And sometimes it can be
a little bit difficult to keep up
with the new technologies.
And now, as a new
professional within the field,
I'm slowly starting to relate
a little bit more to this response.
Us nurses are already really busy.
We're not offered
the opportunity to innovate,
and quite frankly, we're not paid enough.
However,
if we could change this attitude
of innovation earlier on,
during nursing education,
I believe we could have
our future nurses innovate
in a way to improve the working quality
for health care professionals,
which in turn will improve patient care.
This is the key to making
our future nurses the stakeholders
within the future development
of the health care system.
So what is innovation?
It's a bit of an ambiguous word
that can mean a lot of different things
to many different people.
But simply put, innovation
is looking at a problem,
understanding it and trying
to make it better.
And if you make it better,
that's innovation.
Innovation can be applied to something
which already exists,
or it can be used to develop
something completely new.
But before we go deeper into this topic,
let me tell you all a story
which inspired me to have
this speech here today.
When I started my final internship
for my nursing studies at the end of 2020,
I had an interview with the ward
manager on the first day.
One of the questions
which she asked me was,
"So, Ben, where do you see yourself
going in the next five to 10 years?"
Honestly, I had to think about it
for a little while.
And then I told her,
"Well, to be honest, I don't think
I can be a nurse forever.
It's really hard work.
Like, really, really hard.
Both physically and emotionally.
But I am passionate about health care
and would love to pursue a future career
in health care innovation and technology."
And yes, I know some you might think it’s
a little bit strange for a near-graduate
to be planning on leaving his career
on the first day of his internship.
And, you know what she said?
Well, she said,
"Oh, I see.
I'm not too sure about this
whole innovation thing.
I'm not really a big fan."
Whoa, whoa, whoa, OK.
I was taken aback.
See, that's what I wanted to do.
The egotistical part of me
wanted to say,
“What do you mean,
you don’t like innovation?
You don't want to improve the working
quality for health care professionals,
which, in turn,
will improve patient care?”
Well, I didn't say that, obviously.
Instead, I asked her one simple question.
And that was:
"Why?"
And what she told me
gave me the biggest light-bulb moment.
She said,
“Well, too often a businessperson
or an engineer comes to me
with a new technology or innovative idea.
And more often than not,
it's not very user-friendly,
or it just adds more to our workload."
OK.
So I'm standing there and I'm thinking,
Ding!
This is the moment that I realized
that there's a huge disconnect
between the developer and the end user
within the health care sector.
In fact, this isn't the first time
I've gotten this kind of response.
Throughout my studies and now my career,
I've often recognized
that there's a bit of a frustration factor
whenever new technologies
or processes are introduced.
So on our days full of making reports,
taking patients' vitals,
communicating with doctors,
physiotherapists, family members,
taking patients' vitals again and charting
and God, am I forgetting something?
Well, that's honestly on a good day.
But most of the time
we're covering for our colleagues
who are away on sick leave due to burnout,
taking on extra administrative roles
because hospitals
are trying to save money.
And answering call bells.
The call bells.
Especially to independent patients
who all of a sudden can't do anything
for themselves anymore.
So if there's anybody out
there who knows a nurse,
which most of you probably do,
go ahead and ask them to share
a story with you about call bells
and these kinds of patients.
They’re often quite amusing,
but at the time,
oh, so frustrating.
So, yeah,
adding a new technology
or process on top of all of this,
especially when going through
beta stage flaws,
only adds on to the headache.
And you see, nursing is changing.
It's not the same that it was
20 to 30 years ago.
Neither is the health care system,
and it seems like education
has not quite caught up.
A lot of new technologies
are being introduced
and most of nurses' time still being spent
completing mundane and repetitive tasks.
In addition to this,
we're seeing an aging population,
we're seeing an increase
in the cost of care,
patients' needs are more demanding
and a shortage in health care staff.
However, we could have these repetitive
and mundane tasks of charting
aided by AI and technologies as small
as a ring taking patient's vitals.
This would hopefully leave more
time for nurses to communicate
and provide care for their patients,
but also give them an opportunity to solve
problems within their organizations.
In fact, the World
Health Organization estimates
that by 2030
there's going to be
a global health care shortage
with nine million those
being nursing-specific.
This is caused by experienced nurses
coming towards their retirement,
a poor retention rate of new professionals
and less people
entering the field altogether.
It's not looking very good.
So we're at a point now
where we can no longer wait
and see if these advancements
will happen in the health care sector.
We’re at a point now where these
advancements, technologies have to happen.
But who are the ones
who should be driving
these advancements and technologies?
Well, the answer is, frontline
health care workers, nurses.
We're the ones who have been using
all of the technologies
which have been introduced thus far.
We work with them every day,
see where their flaws are,
and some of us might have pretty good
ideas on how to make them better.
But most importantly,
us nurses are the ones
who truly understand
what aspects of our jobs
can be replaced with future technologies.
If we can combine
the frontline experience of nurses
with the innovative approaches
of businesspeople and engineers,
just imagine
the improvements we could see.
We could actually start solving
the problems nurses face every day
by including them, the end user,
within the development phase.
So that comes now to my main question.
How do we solve
this multi-dimensional issue?
It is quite a big one.
Well, a good start would be
by looking into our education system.
From my experience, going through
my bachelor degree in nursing,
they take a bunch of nursing students
where a nurse in the front of the class
teaches them about nursing.
And it makes sense.
But what this does is it creates
a nursing bubble within the university,
and sometimes it can be
a little bit difficult
to penetrate through that barrier.
What it does is it narrows your path
to where what you learn is only useful
for that profession
without exploration and problem solving
within the industry.
As a nursing student going through
a bachelor's degree,
you're merely handed the tools
and taught how to use them.
There's very little emphasis on being able
to look at that tool and thinking,
"Aha, this would work much better
if it was made like this."
And here's the thing.
Universities are networking havens.
We're literally working in establishments
where we have people
working on business and marketing,
IT, engineering, design,
culture, health care.
And that is only the tip of the iceberg.
As a student,
I was lucky enough to be a part of a group
who were really keen
on extracurricular innovation projects.
We had a diverse group of students,
myself a nurse, two industrial designers,
a cultural manager
and a health tech engineer.
This experience taught me so much
about the importance of networking
and how to work within
a multi-professional team.
And I couldn’t help but think
that every single student should have
an opportunity like this
and solve real-life problems.
But most importantly,
it showed me that we needed each other
to make this project become alive.
During the same time,
we also established a nonprofit
which looked at enriching the innovative
and entrepreneurial culture
amongst the university students.
I was lucky to have
an experience like this,
and I should acknowledge
that there are the beginnings
of innovation education
within nursing studies,
but it's at its infancy stage
and not held as a priority
within the classroom.
So if there's any nursing
educators out there,
in fact, all educators
who aren't already doing this, is to --
if there's one thing I would like to ask
is that you let your students
out of that bubble.
Make them professionally
mix and match, interact, network
and work on projects with students
going through different courses
within your university.
From my experience in the projects
that I did with my colleagues,
I can see a huge benefit in this kind
of cross-course collaboration.
What might come out of it
can be truly special,
and the connections you get from them
can last a lifetime.
Now, when you really think about it,
how can we develop easily adoptable
technologies for nurses
if we never get a chance to learn
how to really sit down
and work within a multi-professional team?
So in our future careers
as health care professionals,
when we come across a potential problem,
we can draw from those past experiences
and networks we gained as students
to at least get started
with innovation process.
Now there are many barriers nurses
and health tech developers face
within the health care sector.
Educating our nurses about innovation
and what's to come in the future
of the health care system,
we can slowly start to make them
the stakeholders within the strategy.
However, education is not
an end-all solution.
The solution lies in a more integrative
approach where education, technology,
governance, leadership, laws, finances
are all taken into consideration.
But these are all entire
TEDx Talks in themselves
and outside of my personal experience.
So if there's anybody out there listening
who's an expert within the field,
I would like to invite
somebody to come up here
and speak about how we can start
solving these issues.
We need to get this ball rolling
because time is seriously
starting to run out.
And now, for myself as a new
professional within the field,
if there's a message
that I would like to share,
that is that if you’re a start-up,
innovator, businessperson, engineer
or anybody working on a
health care-related technology or service,
is to get in contact with the nurse.
Ask us how can this product
or service be made better
to suit our needs better.
Trust me, we want to help.
That's kind of why
we're nurses to begin with.
And while I'm on the topic,
I would also like to encourage nurses
and students to get more involved.
Find like-minded people in societies.
These might be part of the hospital
you're working for
or within your local university.
And if you have a business
or innovation idea, share it.
Speak to people and find other services
within your community.
There are health care-related
hackathons, incubators
and other kinds of services to help
you construct these ideas better.
Now, studies have shown
that innovation empowers nurses
when it looks at ways
of improving patient care,
technologies and processes.
However, this is only possible
with financial support,
health care leaders
promoting an environment
where intellectual creativity is promoted
and employees get the recognition
and prestige that they deserve.
However.
Time and time again,
when I've spoken to nurses as a student
and now as a professional,
it seems like there's something
preventing nurses from achieving this.
There's something fundamentally
preventing nurses from innovating more.
Well, nurses are overworked,
burning out, underpaid,
often unappreciated
with their own organizations,
especially within the public sector.
But most importantly,
we aren't offered the opportunity
to truly demonstrate our potential.
Now, as AI and technologies
assume many tasks
of nurses in the near future,
we need to educate and facilitate
our future nurses
to be the stakeholders
within the future development
of the health care system.
Our future nurses will be the health
care information integrators,
health care consultants, health coaches
and providers of human care,
supported by these technologies and AI,
not replaced by them.
After all ...
One of the first human
interactions you have in life
is with a nurse in the maternity ward.
And one of your last will be
with a nurse by your bedside.
The way we support our nurses
in society is a choice.
So please help us nurses
so we can help you innovate.
Let's build a better future together.
Thank you.
(Applause)